1 2 3 4 5
This is the same; tap36 times.
You often tap
It can prevent hair loss and help you sleep better.
memory has also improved!
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
The beautiful woman sitting next to me
She is my hairstylist
Yī jié(transliteration)
She has over 40 years of experience in hairdressing.
More than 40 years
Their ages are all exposed.
Let's giveYī jié(transliteration)a round of applause!
Hi everyone, I'mYī jié(transliteration)
I am Dr. Hu's hairstylist
I'm also a huge fan of his.
Why did I invite Yī jié (transliteration) to my show?
In traditional Chinese medicine, when we diagnose a patient, we first distinguish between internal and external causes.
internal cause external cause
Internal causes of hair loss
It's probably an imbalance between the liver and kidneys.
Insufficient blood and qi supply
And what about external factors?
It often comes from repetitive daily actions.
Improper methods of washing and conditioning hair
Yī jié(transliteration), what do you think about hair loss?
I discovered that...
There are many guests
They are not
naturally prone to hair loss
It's actually because of the wrong way you wash and blow-dry your hair.
Problems leading to hair loss
It's getting worse
It's true!
That's why we've invitedYī jié(transliteration)to teach everyone today
The correct way to wash and condition hair
Hair loss and receding hairline?
One massage technique to promote hair growth and prevent hair loss
Dr. Hu
I have a 50-year-old guest
He knew I was coming on your show!
Let me ask you a question.
He hasn't been sleeping well lately.
Tired all day
Memory also declines
And also
There is also a noticeable problem with hair loss.
He wants to ask you
How to sleep well and improve memory
And how to prevent hair loss?
Come , all these problems of yours
can be improved
with one method
This method is
the head-tapping massage technique
First, clench your hands like this.
Tuck your thumb into your palm
Like this
Let's tap first.
Let's tap the top of our heads first.
1 2 3 4 5 (Tap like this)
The action involves approximately 36 taps
tapagain
side
1 2 3 4 5
This is the same; tap 36 times
tapagain
Front of the forehead
1 2 3 4 5
Also tapit 36 ​​times.
tap
back of the head
1 2 3 4 5
It's the same, tap 36 times
remember
Just these 5 places, tap 36 times.
After you finish tap, you will feel
The scalp feels a little swollen
This indicates that blood circulation has improved.
That’s true
When I was tap
It felt like I was electrocuted
The scalp feels warm and numb
Wow, that's awesome!
Traditional Chinese Medicine said
Fà wèi xuè zhī yú(transliteration)
Hair needs to be nourished by blood and qi.
Tap your head like this
Stimulated in one go
The Dū mài(transliteration) , the páng guāng jīng(transliteration), and the dǎn jīng (transliteration)
These threejīng luò(transliteration)
Bring blood and qi to the scalp
Activate hair follicles
Make hair roots strong
To prevent further hair loss
Ancient books say that the head is zhū yáng zhī huì (transliteration)
Tapping your head
can improve dizziness and memory loss
And you can sleep soundly
at night
When you were combing my hair just now
The editor and my beautiful wife
Everyone says he's quite handsome, really dashing!
When I was combing your hair just now
When you comb your hair to add volume
Of course, looks quite handsome.
Okay, now please share.
How can comb hair
to make it more voluminous
and fuller
If you have
thin, soft, and fine hair
Like me
When wake up and look in the mirror
You notice your hair is flat and limp.
This hair combing method
You definitely have to try it!
First, use a comb.
Comb your hair forward from the back of your head.
Not combing along the hair.
Untangle the knots
When washing hair
So your hair won't get tangled
So it won't pull your scalp
When you comb your hair from back to front
Comb your hair like this every day
The scalp will become elastic
Your hair will become fluffy!
These two methods are simple and practical.
Have you learned it?
How to deal with postpartum menopausal hair loss
5 Foods to Eat for Thinning Hair
Many girls have this feeling
When was young, stayed up late and ate whatever wanted
The hair can still hold up
Over 40 years old
How to maintain and massage
hair keeps falling out
Why is this happening?
The 3 most common reasons
Liver and kidney deficiency, qi and blood deficiency
Also, gān yù qì zhì(transliteration)
I'll start with the first one
Liver and kidney deficiency
Postpartum or around menopause
Her estrogen levels began to drop.
Traditional Chinese medicine says that this indicates insufficient liver blood.
The hair follicles are not getting enough nutrition.
As a result, my hair became thinner and drier.
It falls off easily.
Someone like this
hair keeps falling out
What to eat
It will take time for hair to grow back
5 delicious foods
Black sesame seeds, walnuts, black beans, goji berries, and yam.
These foods can all help you
Tonify the liver and kidneys
Make hair
black and thick
The second one is
Hair loss due to deficiency of Qi and blood
Fà wèi xuè zhī yú(transliteration)
Your Qi and blood are insufficient.
Insufficient blood supply to the scalp
The hair follicle is like a cell phone that has run out of battery
How do you press?
They can't even turn on, right?
Hair loss caused by qi and blood deficiency
What kind of soup to drink?
Sì wù tāng(transliteration)
I watched Dr. Hu's program.
Men can also drinkSì wù tāng(transliteration)
Not bad, you really have a good grasp of things!
People who often feel tired
and have a pale complexion
Come and have a bowl of sì wù jī tāng (transliteration)
It's great for replenishing your blood and nourishing your hair!
The third
Gān yù qì zhì(transliteration)
High stress and bad mood
Poor circulation of Qi and blood
Let you wake up
There was hair on the pillow.
I really have seen some customers.
When under a lot of pressure
His scalp and neck were very taut.
There is also a lot of hair loss.
People under a lot of pressure
You can eat it often
jīn zhēn (transliteration)
Like jīn zhēn (transliteration) pork rib soup
jīn zhēn (transliteration) are known as
daylily
Did you know?
It can calm the nerves and soothe emotions.
And if the qi flows smoothly
Hair loss will naturally decrease
Not aging
3 bad habits that cause you to lose a lot of hair
Traditional Chinese medicine diagnoses illnesses by considering both internal and external factors.
Hair loss is related to internal organs, etc.
Your hair washing habits are bad
Based on your observation
What are some bad habits?
This will cause hair loss.
The first is frequently dyeing and perming your hair
The second reason is that the hair was not washed properly
The third one: going to sleep without drying the hair
Let me start with the first one.
If you frequently dye or perm your hair
please pay attention!
These products contain various chemical components.
It will irritate your scalp
Makes hair follicles more fragile
Hair becomes thinner
I’m asking for my follower
Hair dyeing and perming
Which one deals more damage?
biggest damage
will be to your wallet
To be honest
Dyeing hair is more damaging than perming.
Many mothers and grandmothers love beauty.
As soon as a little bit of gray hair grows out
just want to dye gray hair black.
This type is the most damaging to the scalp.
I suggest that between coloring your hair and the next coloring
Between perming hair and perming hair
The interval should be at least 3 months.
Give your scalp time to repair.
To prevent hair from getting damaged quickly
The second
Did not wash hair properly
Share with you
How do wash hair properly?
So that won't lose a lot of hair
I will say the most important thing three times.
must wash hair twice
Wash twice
Did you understand?
The first time is to wash away the dirt from your hair.
The second wash is to clean your scalp.
You comb your hair before washing it.
Then wet your hair with warm water
Squeeze an appropriate amount of shampoo onto your hand
Some people directly
apply shampoo to their scalp
Never do this
This will prevent it from getting clean.
Doing this for a long time will cause
hair loss
First, lather up the ends of your hair.
Then massage the scalp for 3-5 minutes.
Rinse with warm water
You'll find that washing like this
Shampoo
is easy to rinse off the hair
Because it’s lathered properly
Shampoo will not leave residue on hair
It will not be easy to lose hair
The third habit that damages hair is
went to sleep with hair still wet
Many people work all day
was very tired when got home.
Blow-dry your hair quickly after washing it.
Some people are even too lazy to blow-dry their hair
The editor just asked me
Do I have to blow-dry my hair completely?
Of course, it is necessary
This is important
This is a sentence I often remind my guests of
Hair not dry
Hair follicles are in a moist state
for a long time
Easy to breed bacteria and mold
Causes folliculitis
Over time, hair follicle function deteriorates.
Your hair will fall out more and more
How to choose the right shampoo
One secret to choosing the right shampoo
Do some people worry that washing their hair every day
will make them fall out more easily?
Should wash every day
or every two days?
Or do you not wash it at all?
Customers often ask me
I will tell the guests
You can wash it every day
If you experience itching easily after washing every day
it's usually not a problem caused by washing every day
It's not that didn't choose the right shampoo.
So how do you choose
the right shampoo for yourself?
First observe your scalp
How long does it take for the oil to come out?
If you wash your hair
By noon the next day, bangs were oily.
Flat hair roots
This is oily scalp.
If it takes 1 to 1.5 days for oil to come out...
This is a neutral scalp.
If your scalpdoesn't get oily for two days
This is dry scalp.
Observe in this way
You can then choose the right shampoo for you.
Today,Yī jié(transliteration)and I will share with you...
Methods to nourish hair and prevent hair loss
Have you learned it?
Do you have
any other hair care secrets?
Please share with me!
Is this your hair?
How could so much fall?
Hey, my wig.
Why did you take my wig?
This is my wig.
So it was your wig.
Dear fans
We have launched the membership channel.
If you agree with my promotion of Traditional Chinese Medicine
The concept of taking care of one's own health
Small monthly donations are welcome.
It only costs the price of two cups of coffee!
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you by my side
Only then can we go further.
Thank you so much!